Thank You spider-man I'm so good
hey sorry I'm late happy look nice thank
you you too thank you
new dress yes it is how'd you get all
what just happened
putting a trip mm-hmm go to Europe
school trip
let's get your passport Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please
many toothpaste pack your suit I just
want to go on my trip with my friends
Europe doesn't really need it from the
neighborhood's
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no that's not a nice thing this
you you look pretty too I just play some
time with MJ watch dude I'll do my first
solo I had just finished my coffee
so nice to finally meet you
in spite of man
your Nick Fury what some clothes on
let's go for a ride
is he gonna be okay like that might want
to turn him over so he doesn't swallow
his tongue
the Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
[Music]
get gifts Parker but have a job to do
are you going to step up or not
they're all alone your friends are in
trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]